um you talked about going to the forest
and doing shrooms with your mom yeah
that was the best you have a a very uh
highly documented uh incident at an
airport where you guys oh yeah yeah that
almost happened to me once and the dude
was cool enough to just throw him away
yeah I had too many of them was it the
TSA guy that hit you
uh man you know I've been on on uh
extra security list for a lot of years
okay uh so that you already you already
were flagged kind of I was flagged since
the time I was like 19. but you know
it's funny because I was actually
um I was cutting my antidepressants cold
turkey I've been on
15 antidepressant medications you were
medicated pretty heavily since I was 18.
I've been on Alexa Pro Zoloft Effexor
Wellbutrin Prozac you name it probably
about 10 to 15 medicines over a span of
about 10 to 15 years and I've realized
that those medicines were making my
mental health worse if I stopped taking
the medicine they were making me
suicidal at times when I wasn't that
when I began taking the medicine yeah so
I heard that those are very bad so I
decided I'm going to cut the medicine
basically cold turkey and replace it
with microdosing like a non-psychoactive
very small dose of mushrooms and I
figured man going to Ghana this would be
the perfect time you know I'll be
in a more beautiful environment in a
more peaceful place and it'll be a great
time and you're going out there for your
Festival
this was the year before okay this was
the year before that
um but we were laying the groundwork for
the festival and uh yeah you know I had
all these micro dose things because I
reached out to different companies to
send me stuff they sent me way more than
I asked for I threw it in a bag was
bringing it back with me and you know
boom got slammed and I'm all over the
news and XYZ but you know what was Ill
about it was like
I was so deep in my meditation at the
time I was used to meditating for hours
on end yeah so the moment I realized I'm
getting locked up I didn't start
stressing I started meditating I'm just
I'm like in a cell like
um you know what I'm saying and uh
mentally I was light years away I was
back on the beach in Ghana and I was
like manifesting my freedom and just my
blessing from the moment when it started
to go left so when they called me and
they're like okay the lawyer is going to
be uh 20K just to start a retainer you
want the good one or do you want the you
know cheaper lawyer I said man just give
me the lawyer you know
um because I I told myself I thank God
that this money has been returned to me
in a perfect time in a perfect way yeah
and the day I got out was Wednesday
Thursday DJ Oreo brought me to come and
do a club performance at Tao in Chicago
handed me twenty thousand dollars cash
the next day I was like oh this [__]
really work you know whatever I was
trying to do before and you know
trying to scam this and trap that yeah
you know I mean I could just move in an
upright way with intention and with a
positive energy and the universe will
give me that [__] yeah I mean I don't
have to PPP that [__] you know what I
mean boys was eating bruh I was gonna
say has would you say shrooms uh because
I'm a big shroom guy I think that you
know I know it I think in Oregon you're
that for therapeutic purposes there's
like
full legalization they're doing like
psilocybin therapy in Oregon for like
people with PTSD that's basically the
way I do it now you know
um I'm sober except for the Psychedelic
stuff and I use it in a healing capacity
like its original purpose like an
indigenous medicine so I peeped those
psychological uh clinical trials that
they're doing and it's about an eighth
adjusted for your body mass and they'll
put you in a in a room like basically a
hospital room with like eye mask and
ambient music in your ears and that's
the way I started doing the shrooms and
I'll be either in a dark room with an
eye mask and earplugs or
ambient music and just go into my mind
you know what I mean and use it to like
deconstruct a lot of the fear and just
like
negative emotions and confusion that
naturally comes from living the way we
live yeah I think what people don't
understand is like if you eat shrooms
with intent you'll you'll get something
out of it now if you're partying and
you're like I want to eat some [__]
shrooms at the club you're gonna get
that out of it too you also might freak
out you might freak out but that's what
I realized too is like since I started
to treat it in the way that I treat it
like with respect and reverence I don't
have bad trips right because I'm not
running from anything I'm not just
taking this to try to have just a jolly
old time I'm taking it because you want
to confront something I want to confront
something and I wanted to reveal things
to me so
there's not really such a thing as a bad
trip if I'm not afraid to confront
whatever is coming and if I'm not trying
to dictate the way that this would work
like my problem with mushrooms in the
past when I was a kid was that I started
to lean on them as a crutch creatively
and I got to a point where I felt like I
had to use mushrooms to make Dope music
that's when it stopped working that's
when I started having bad trips so
that's when I moved on yeah because
you're using it as a crutch for
something and it's not that's not what
it's supposed to be for and for me that
had a that had a expiration date each
time I remember right when the mushrooms
started to not work so then I did Somali
and wrote an amazing song you know and I
was like okay this is my new crutch and
that stopped working
started snorting Adderall that stopped
working started doing coke yeah you know
I mean that never worked in the first
place yeah I've never done cocaine but I
I mean you're not missing out on it
that's what I've heard you know you know
it's crazy to Adderall [__] I don't
think a lot of people talk about it but
like yo man in the music industry the
creative industry Adderall is running
rampant because a lot of these guys who
have to stay up at it engineer a lot of
dudes they kind of depend as adderall as
a crutch because it really is like it
keeps I mean you could speak to it
you've done it I heard it's kind of like
what's that Bradley Cooper movie where
he takes the uh Limitless Limitless I
heard it's like like a like a limitless
type of situation because if you want to
get a bunch of [__] done
you know I got homies who'll edit a
whole [__] complex music video in
like one night because they're off of an
Adderall but like I feel like a lot of
creatives
are dependent on that right now all that
[__] just doesn't work forever right and
it fries your neural Pathways and like
you're gonna burn out on that [__]
that's what I mean the calm down is
crazy from
Mali to the Adderall which are really
two sides of the same coin it's
amphetamines
um it's synthetic serotonin it's pumping
your brain full of dopamine and feel
good chemicals
um but when you're off the drugs now
your body's not able to produce those
things in the same way so you get what
they call suicide Tuesday and you just
be mad depressed because you've used all
the serotonin and it's just not
sustainable like so I started to seek
out natural ways to spike my serotonin
so I got deeply into meditation because
when you meditate that makes your
serotonin levels Spike like 30 percent
you know crazy massages give you
serotonin uh spending time in nature
have you done the deprivation tank in
the water yeah I did that a while back I
heard if you do that
like you could kind of like trip balls
low-key if you're in there long enough
just with nothing you can straight trip
off breathing yeah I'd be doing like
deep breath work you know I mean there's
one I do called the Wim Hof breathing
method
um and like
you know it's a lot of deep breaths and
then you hold your breath you do that
for 30 minutes like you'd be high like
you could trip with absolutely nothing
just off your breath